in this video we'll be talking about
oligodendrocytes which are one type of
gal cell so oligodendrocytes are type of
gal cell which play a crucial role in
milina the aons of our central nervous
system
oligodendrocytes out that this gal
insulation is essential for the nerve
conduction
in an efficient manner so this
insulation not only protects from
mechanical damage but it also provides
an electrical insulation prevents ion
leakage it improvise the speed of action
potential conduction due to these kind
of mine Sheed it is possible to have
salary conduction in the central nervous
system neurons also from an energy
perspective this is quite
efficient now let's look look at
oligodendrocyte from an morphological
perspective having small cell bodies
with multiple processes each of these
processes reach several axons and can
form a milein sheath around
it now oligodendrocytes are pretty much
typical for the central nervous
system when it comes to the peripheral
nervous system we found an equivalent
cell type known as Schwan cells Schwan
cels also form the mine Sheed but in the
peripheral nervous system it's important
to note that while Schwan Cel mate only
single axon one
oligodendrocyte multiple axons these are
the key difference between these two
cell types also they location where they
are found oligodendrocytes are generated
from
oligodendrocytes which are inter present
in the brain whereas the Schwan cells
are actually neural crest cell deriv d d
now let's look at the timeline of uh
oligodendrocyte development takes place
from early gestation so if this is a
gestation timeline from a gestational
week 10 to 18 olgod dendrite progenitor
cells are formed eventually
oligodendrocytes give rise to immature
oligodendrocytic processes which are
mult which are morphologically more
complex than the
ually they form connection with the
neurons at around GW 28 to 40 in human
embryo and now they form mature
oligodendrocyte but wait a second how
can one tell from molecular perspective
these are different stages of igod dendy
development well different molecular
markers can actually differentiate
between these cellular States for
example the
oligodendrogenesis G2 and pdgf Alpha and
they're highly enriched in these
cellular State olig 1 and olig 2 is
highly enriched in imature
oligodendrocytes whereas mature
oligodendrocytes proteins like mine
basic protein MVP MOG and
PLP So based on these molecular marker
they are distinguishable it's important
to note that that olgod dendrite
progenitor cells have the capability of
selfrenewal so they can divide and
multiply
so during the development neural stem
cells can eventually give rise to neuron
astrocytes and
oligodendrocytes the internal and the
external signals triggers the formation
of
oligodendrocyte function can be
abrogated in diseases like multiple
sclerosis multiple sclerosis is
characterized by Progressive destruction
of the mine sheep she surrounding the
Aon of central nervous system so overall
the milein sheath is destroyed in this
particular
disease so destruction of the milein
Sheed lead to different neurological
symptoms which occurs
progressively now we already learned
that mature
oligodendrocyte like mine basic protein
proteolipid or
PLP mine
so all of these are endogenous to mature
oligodendrocytic to the body immune
system should not treat it as a foreign
but in case of uh multiple sclerosis the
immune system the autoreactive tea cells
can recognize these protein they can
activate B cells which eventually
differentiate into plasma cells and
secrete antibody against these oloy
proteins now they can trigger an immune
response in that particular region which
eventually destroys the mine Sheed in an
complement mediated
pathway so this is what happens in
multiple sclerosis also there are
different other t- cell differentiation
takes place such as th1 subtype and th17
each of these cell types secretes
inflammatory cyto mines which makes the
situation even
worse so overall in multiple sclerosis
we understand that compared to a healthy
brain there are several scar formation
in the central nervous system or even in
the white matter tracts so loss of
mation is a Hallmark of multiple
sclerosis so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can support our
Channel using super thanks which is a
hardship icon with Dollar in it you can
contribute using PTM PayPal or UPI see
you in next
video